because so promethium is actually my
least favorite lanthanide because i
can't actually work with it
it's highly radioactive and at any one
time on the Earth's surface there is not
an awful lot of it so you can't
physically get enough of it to do any
chemistry with so Promethean is the only
one of the rare earth elements that is
radioactive but because it's radioactive
in the atoms decay away it's not found
in nature so it was only after the start
of nuclear research that people
discovered promethium aidan some of the
products from the decay of other
radioactive elements and you can see
this quite well this is an old chemistry
book that I've got written by Aston the
famous scientist who discovered isotopes
atoms of the same element that have
different weights and in this book which
he published in 1922 he had a periodic
table and if you look down here here are
the rare earths and in this position
here there is a space for element 61
promethium so element 61 wasn't known in
1922 and it was found known much later
but you can see the rest of the elements
were except there's a gap down here
after tungsten because again the element
rhenium was only discovered relatively
recently compared to most of the other
elements